i want to talk let's call michael moore
oh let's do that
yeah all right so dial him up maybe
he'll answer we do that well let's set
it up pete and i you know you found out
i was friends with michael moore yes and
then michael moore and i have a comedy
festival in february yes you're all
invited and um it's in uh traverse city
michigan yeah so get there on your own
but yeah but if you say i was at pete's
taping i'll hook you up and by that he
means he'll raft you across the river
you have to take to get to traverse city
the guy taking the tickets is a grizzly
bear
all right anyhow so i told you i did and
then he's done it for michael moore
michael moore loves it i love doing the
impression so this is michael moore
narrating any of his films it's
basically just this
the plant shut down that day
my dad
my dad worked at gm for 40 years
until they built a robot
and replaced him and the robot was built
by al qaeda
all right that's all it takes no but
he may not be there we'll try
there it doesn't say his number so he's
safe
your call has been forwarded
voice message system
michael
is not available we know it's you
when you have finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
it was the summer of 1971
and my dad had just gotten a job
until he was replaced
by a man
sent by george w bush
i'm so nervous leaving him a message why
he he loves your thing hi michael it's
your dad
all right
he'll know it's you he will know it's
you he'll know it's me okay
now it just got quiet and we're both
okay with that by the way let me tell
you something
it is it is one of the greatest things
that you can do for anyone and that's
have a lull
yeah allow
lulls are fantastic lull it up low it up
lullapalooza embrace the lull and it
shows you're confident it's a fun it's a
fun time i'm pro low i'm pro low yeah
let's just suck it up the lull let's go
the path to an lol is paved with a lull
so allow comes from a wool
true it's like if dr seuss never died
i thought you were gonna spit well i
have to have water in my mouth to do it
you have to time it perfect
go ahead by the way you know if you
didn't take the class a comedy
at comedy college which was setting up
yeah yeah yeah and they have people in
there like spit takes happening but you
have there's a certain
way you can't go to the well too many
times
koreans